[Music]
oh no it's a code red code paper okay
we're late let's roll let's go i'm zoe
dj let's go
up and adam and this is paul morning jay
we turned our two families into one all
right rise and shine
wake up ella or this video goes on your
instagram in three two dad no touch me
lose a finger good morning to you too
[Music]
luna strong choice suggestion take off
one thing solid advice
dryer's broke again how did you get down
here so fast laundry shoes let's go
let's go let's go
we're not a cult oh but we're weird
we're one of a kind all the way thank
you thank you very much thank you thank
you thanks
i really feel like there were a few
extra children in there i didn't
recognize some of them
where are the bakers
ten kids and no nanny wait you have 10
kids shockingly i enjoy being with my
kids
i do too you too yeah i do too
you guys are funny no you can't
go to your
room do our tick-tock dance with us
because we're so irresistibly adorable
you're not even doing it right you have
to clap the back of the hands and then
throw you're embarrassing the family go
to your room oh lord get me strength
it's important to show the kids that
we're united who invited the jackson 9.
if y'all looking for disneyland you made
a wrong turn
family has each other's back oh my god
everyone's looking at us
i know
thanks for being so average and
relatable paul with average looks and
ordinary body wow
what are you guys playing good grace fun
i love rupaul
it's not what it seems so you guys
weren't having a fast and furious style
race for money whoa
i just realized we're not smarter than
you
[Music]
bye